I new CBS News poll finds most Americans
do not support the last-ditch Republican
effort to repeal and replace Obamacare
just 20 percent approve of the bill
written by senators Lindsey Graham and
Bill Cassidy 52 percent disapprove
poll also finds eighty-seven percent
believe insurance companies should be
required to cover people with
pre-existing conditions Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill where over the weekend
several key Republicans came out against
the bill Nancy good morning good morning
and those defections have all but killed
this bill's prospects which is why
Graham and Cassidy rushed out a new
version of the bill last night one that
they say delivers more funding to the
states of some of these GOP holdout
states like Alaska Arizona and Maine but
it's not clear that that move is going
to sway these no votes like John McCain
who has said that the process was
already too rushed or Rand Paul who
believes that the bill is already too
expensive Ted Cruz of Texas and Susan
Collins of Maine are also leaning no she
says she's worried about Medicaid
recipients and people with pre-existing
conditions so right there you have
enough Republicans to sink the bill but
Graham and Cassidy are going ahead with
a planned hearing today anyway and they
say they're still hoping for a vote
later this week on this bill that takes
most Obama care funding and hands it
over to the states to come up with their
own plans a move that a lot of
Republicans believe would give States
more flexibility but the time for
changes and wheeling and dealing is
really running out gale because if
Republicans want to pass a health care
bill in the Senate with a simple
majority Senate rules say they only have
until Saturday after that they'd need 60
votes where they have a lot of work to
do there thank you very much Nancy